welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Kamari Clarke professor of
anthropology at Yale University and
chair of the Council on African Studies
at the Macmillan Center professor
Clark's areas of research explore issues
related to religious nationalism legal
institutions international law the
interface between culture and power and
its relationship to the modernity of
race and late capitalist globalization
her recent articles and books have
focused on religious and legal movements
and the related production of knowledge
and power including the 2004 publication
of mapping Yoruba networks power and
agency in the making of transnational
communities today we'll talk with
Professor Clark about her newest book
fictions of Justice the International
Criminal Court and the challenge of
legal pluralism in sub-saharan Africa
welcome professor Clark thank you thank
you very much please tell us about the
premise of your book well mapping yerba
networks was my earlier book and in that
book I attempted to think through how
one would do an anthropology that goes
beyond spatial configurations in this
book fictions of Justice what I attempt
to do is is take on some of the same
conceptual trajectories but instead map
them through legal frameworks and thus
the title fictions of justice it's an
attempt to think about that which
constitutes justice to ask questions
about the very things that seem to be
natural and straight forward often when
we talk about justice when we say
justice has been done etc it we presume
that we all mean the same thing and the
book really is an exploration over the
controversies of justice the both
transnational and national I examine an
emergent movement the rise of the
International Criminal Court the
formation of the court as well as the
stations related to the the making of
the International Criminal Court what we
call the ICC okay what is the ICC and
what countries fall under its
jurisdiction right yes well the ICC is
is known to most as an independent
international judiciary so it has the
teeth of of a court as one would expect
it there 110 countries that are member
states that are under the jurisdiction
of the court countries from every part
of the world really the u.s. is not a
signatory but their number of countries
many many countries that are more than
half of the world's nation states are
are under the jurisdiction of the court
okay and why focus on sub-saharan Africa
why did you pick there well um part of
the world yeah it well I'm an African
estoy also an American astir force and
so in many ways analytically it made
sense for me to examine what was
happening in this region visa vie the
you know why state sign international
treaties and why this treaty in
particular but some of the
decision-making really wasn't mine the
first case is our african-based cases
they're not you know china-based cases
they're not Latin American base cases
they're african-based cases so it was
also quite straight forward that yes
indeed i followed the cases more than
followed my own research areas ok so the
term legal pluralism what is it and what
is the challenge in sub-saharan Africa
right yeah that's and that's precisely
the subtext of the book the challenge of
legal pluralism in sub-saharan Africa
well legal pluralism is somewhat of a
new concept I guess a twentieth-century
concept that emerged out of an interest
to think about dual legal systems that
coexist and a lot of legal scholars
legal anthropologists the range of
critical legal theorists etc have used
it almost as a as a way to go beyond
term known as relativism right so to go
beyond relativism but to think about the
ways that systems coexist and come
eat my argument are part of the premise
is that we have to go beyond this
conception beyond the notion of
plurality that that legal systems
coexist I the the challenge is that the
systems coexist in relations of power
they coexist alongside other
negotiations that are connected to other
powerful very powerful institutions the
World Bank the IMS IMF powerful
nationalist movements etc and to simply
see them as legal systems that exist in
and of themselves without looking at
systems of hegemony the ways that these
systems work in relation to other
spheres of power is to miss read the
coexistence of legal systems and so the
attempt is to to not only look at these
legal systems alongside each other so
the rise of Islamic sharia in northern
Nigeria alongside the emergence of ICC
power right it's to go beyond simply
looking at the dualities and instead to
think about what are some of the other
dynamics that are at play here what are
the power relations wire States signing
these treaties in the first place so so
really the attempt is to go beyond
simply this comparative frame and to
think about the power relations that
sometimes imbalances complexities that
are fundamental to the the so-called
coexistence of these legal spheres so
what methodology did you use in your
book how did you gather the data yeah
it's it's it's a good question actually
and and my methods were somewhat
unorthodox in the sense that I'm a
cultural anthropologist who is
interested in international relations
has some background in political science
and the methods that I use in their
ethnography it involves doing
ethnography but it's transnational and
multi-sided ethnography it involved I
mean in your most North most Orthodox
tway doing interviews of course doing
focus groups doing standard observations
that any social scientists would would
engage in but it also in
involved late nights after a diplomatic
herring a closed session at the bar
drinking having a few drinks to hear you
know to debrief what the the latest
controversy was at a given meeting or it
involved me going to law school for a
year to learn the fundamentals of of
criminal law and and some basic legal
jurisprudential questions it also
involved working with NGOs in various
parts of sub-saharan Africa so doing
some constitutional reform work so some
engaged what we call engaged ethnography
which goes beyond simply data collection
but also participant and participate
participation and engaged political
mobilization related work and and that
is often seen as a less Orthodox
approach but but I tell you this kind of
work this kind of transnational quite
messy work that examines an emergent
movement that has many tentacles in many
different places involves quite messy
methodology so those were those are the
highlights of the work you know
something just dawned on me when you
said you know you would go to the
courtroom and then you know afterwards
go to the bar it dawned on me where does
the International Criminal Court travel
around to different countries based on
the trials they are hearing or is it in
one location right well the court that
the building the structure you know the
thing called the International Criminal
Court is in the hague okay just it's in
the hague it's and it's in the
netherlands but before it it was in The
Hague it the the court was really an
idea in 1998 the signing of the the Rome
Statute led to the concept and from the
concept there were preparatory committee
meetings at the UN so every couple of
months or every four months or so
diplomats from around the world would
converge to work on this document that
then became the the International
Criminal Court that became the
Constitution that was fundamentally the
constitution of the court so it was an
idea that became a building but still it
lives outside of the structure and I
think
that's what is quite interesting and
phenomenal about this this thing this
movement this movement that exists
alongside the the rise of the rule of
law around the world really but yes to
you know in a straightforward way there
it is a building and it's a building
that houses many from the the defense
prosecutor to the lead prosecutor to the
judges to to the you know the audience
the people who who visit and and and
watch the cases it is it is a building
that's housed in The Hague okay let's
talk about your findings what
conclusions have you reached tell us
about some of them well there are
numbers of conclusions are two prongs in
in some ways because i'm writing to
multiple audiences in this book and it's
it's quite the challenge on one hand i'm
writing to for anthropologists I'm
engaging notions of legal pluralism I'm
thinking about transnational
methodologies how one studies up as it
were in historically anthropologists
have tended to study local people in a
way in villages etc and this has changed
tremendously over the last decade and
and so I'm in conversation with
anthropologist thinking about the
limitations of this concept called legal
pluralism thinking about the fictions of
this notion that we know as justice and
trying to shift the debate in a way to
push us to think about emergent
movements and hegemonic movements
movements that are that are
fundamentally intertwined with the whole
set of other new and emerging legal
institutions the other is I'm in
conversation with NGOs and with sort of
government and with the prosecutors and
lawyers and human rights activists were
part of the court and in part I'm asking
them and thinking through this this idea
of justice but also thinking about the
the methods of deliberation right how
how might we envision a different world
in a different constitution or a
different statute what are the problems
of the contemporary statute what kinds
of conversations
do we need to be having in order to
think through what justice might mean in
these other domains these other locales
and this is all part of a conversation
an ongoing one that I have and I'm
having with them it's not always a
popular one my position isn't
necessarily a popular one among NGO
activists etc but it's an important one
it's certainly a conversation that needs
to be had and then lastly what is the
most surprising thing you found in doing
the research for fictions of Justice and
and and writing the book yeah the most
surprising probably was how different
people's definitions of what justice is
our one person's justice is another
person's retribution one person's
justice is another person's pain and I
actually thought that I perhaps was had
a sense that there was more in common
than not and after almost eight nine
years of research in this area realized
that that this this concept is a concept
that is quite far reaching and is
fundamentally culturally constructed and
means everything and nothing to the very
same people who are being asked what
justice is so that's probably the most
surprising okay well thank you so much
for being here with us today and sharing
some of your research well thank you for
having me Marilyn for more information
about professor Clark and your work
please visit our website at yale edu
backslash macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you